imagine what life would be like if you
stopped fighting your body and felt at
home in it wellness by kelly the
sponsors of this next segment can help
you achieve that state let's welcome the
show kelly namiro it's great to have you
back thank you so much for having me
first of all congratulations to on the
newborn last time you were here you were
doing training jillian you were pregnant
at the time i was pregnant and we were
doing pilates on the floor over there
and now i have a two-month-old
congratulations that's awesome so what's
the biggest health concern that people
come to you with the biggest health
concern that people come to me with is
women's hormone issues so typically they
won't know what's going on with their
bodies they'll just say to me hey i feel
really bloated i feel like i have a
weight i've gained and i can't lose it
my hair is falling out and then it's my
job to figure out why so how are you
different than a doctor
so i'm different than a doctor because a
doctor really doesn't have too much time
the average doctor visit is under 10
minutes whereas the average time that i
spend with my clients is anywhere from
an hour to an hour and a half so we have
a lot of time to explore what's going on
and a lot of times doctors will offer
you a pill as the solution my solution
is getting to the root cause and
changing your habits so you have a
sustainable solution well you're kind of
changing things from the inside exactly
so why why are hormones probably
probably an easy question but why are
hormones so important then yes so our
hormones dictate how we feel especially
for us women
we like we can feel like our moods our
weight our hair our nails our skin how
fast we age all of that is dictated by
our hormones and so when those things
are out of balance we can feel really
crappy inside and think that it's normal
we're taught to think a lot of times
that it's normal and it's not it's just
really common so what are some things
that can trigger our hormones to get off
track great question so diet how
stressed you are that's the number one
thing i see nowadays is like everyone
walks around so stressed we're either if
we're not like actually working we're
checking email we're checking social
media we our brains never have a second
to reset so
diet stress exercise how much alcohol
you're drinking all of those things
really control i mean and more control
your hormones we could go on and on but
we don't realize how much control we
have over our own health
and we do and kelly here you're
fascinating we were talking beforehand
before we wrap up here i want to talk
about uh mental wellness yes is there a
little trick someone watching right now
that they can use to kind of improve
their their mental wellness and mental
well-being so i was actually telling
this to a client today and i think that
it's a super helpful tip
instead of like constantly walking
around and all of us saying i'm so
overwhelmed i'm so overwhelmed pausing
when you feel that overwhelm and say how
am i contributing to this sense of
overwhelm right now what could i be
doing differently and a lot of times for
me that's like putting my phone away in
another room for a few minutes whatever
that might be for you so notice how
you're contributing to your own sense of
overwhelm and that's just one like
negative mental side effects there's
anxiety there's depression there's all
these different things but i think that
how am i contributing to my sense of
overwhelm is super helpful and also
if you don't meditate
start by just taking three deep breaths
in the morning before you get out of bed
and check your phone i think that's huge
i think there's an intimidation factor
when it comes to meditation but as
simple as wake up in the morning just
grounding yourself thinking about a few
things that you're grateful for rather
than rolling into your day and starting
it with emails and social medias and
everybody else's to-do list for you you
start your day on your own thank you so
much kelly thank you to wellness by
kelly for sponsoring this segment for
more information visit
wellnessbykelly.com
ten percent off memberships and courses
right now and